hallo leider hielt wieder eure mal wanne
und ja es ist geschehen
ich habe verdammt noch mal mein tagebuch
wieder die story dahinter ist einfach so
unglaubwürdig dass man meinen könnte
dass ich mir ausgedacht habe eines tages
habe ich den papiermüll untergebracht
und in der papiertonne lag das tagebuch
obendrauf als ob es da auf mich gewartet
hätte und mehr gibt's dazu nichts zu
sagen ich hab's wieder mit nach oben
und jetzt hab ich der nachbar der erst
geklaut hat muss es wohl einfach daheim
geschmissen haben weil er vielleicht
durch barmittel story und sich dachte
langweilige geschichte schon wieder über
vier monate her dass ich das letzte mal
aus meinem tagebuch vorgelesen habe und
ich habe mir vorhin die letzte folge
angeschaut und es hat damit geendet dass
ich nach polen gefahren bin das ich
robin handynummer bekommen habe und dass
man irgendwie nicht mehr vorkam warum
auch immer und ich kann euch nicht sagen
wie gespannt ich drauf bin was jetzt
noch passiert wirklich sie entspannt
letztes mal war der zehnte zehnte 2005
und jetzt ist der elfte 2005 vanessa oft
ich kann man sich verlassen liebes
tagebuch sophie hört einfach nicht auf
dich zu umarmen
das nervt na ja er ist ja ganz süß aber
ich betrug robben nicht
da hatte ich angst dass mein tagebuch
denkt dass ich eine bin wenn ich jemand
anderen süßen und musste gleich erklären
euch betrügen ich wirklich bin ich bin
eine treue seele bachmann
glaubst du er mag mich auch kann doch
sein aber warum macht er dieses
praktikum bei vanessa plus frau bekommen
warum machst du dieses praktikum ihn
schon so lange nicht gesehen weil er
nicht mehr schule soll ein praktikum
macht alles so ablief
gleis 17 12 2005 das ist jetzt über
mathematik zwei monate und sechs tage
sind jetzt dazu ich liebe es in meinem
universum heisters die ganze welt hat
sich verändert reiter die in letzter
zeit ist viel passiert
oh mein gott habe ich an alina hat meine
sms gelesen in denen dumme sachen stehen
ich bin ja auch blöd was schreibe ich so
einen scheiß zu ihm am anfang war ich
immer ich selbst doch durch sophie habe
ich mich ganz schön verändert ich habe
jetzt schon lange abstand von ihm
gehalten vielleicht sage ich ihm dass
ich in ihn verliebten ich weiß es nicht
vanessa verbrauchen mehr herd und
trauben und ein bunt und reuters man die
story kann ich mich noch ganz genau
erinnern ich bin irgendwann mal nach
hause kommt von der schule und meine
schwester und meine mutter saß in der
küche und habe schon auf mich gewartet
und meine schwester hatte mein handy in
da haben was ich mich mit in die schule
genommen hat weil wir keine handys
nehmen durften und ich hatte ja robbins
handynummer und habe angefangen mit dem
sms zu schreiben und durch meine
freundin sophie die ein bisschen ich
würde mal früher sagen war ja früher
reif basis ein nettes wort frühere
halter voraus und ich arbeite robin
nachrichten geschrieben wie man nicht
indem einer hätte schreiben sollen und
mensch was hat sie gelesen und mensch
hat sie meine mama gezeigt und dann
haben sie mich zum gespräch in die küche
gebeten und ich weiß noch bis heute es
war der schlimmste peinlichste moment in
meinem leben zu der zeit weil das so
unangenehm weist mich darauf
angesprochen habe dort mein nachbar
gleich noch laut und ich konnte nicht
mal sauer auf meine schwäche sein dass
sie meine nachrichten gelesen hat ohne
mich zu fragen alle es mir so unangenehm
war ich wusste dass ich in dem moment so
richtig verpackt habe ich habe auch
aufgehört danach in welche komischen
sachen zu schreiben und daraus wirklich
gelernt ich mich ein bisschen so wie
heute bin ich eher dankbar
das war der siebzehnte zwölfte 2005 und
jetzt kommt der 29 11 2006 einfach ein
jahr später
ok meine abschiedsworte 29 d elfter
zeitung sechs meine abschiedsworte an
dieses tagebuch liebes tagebuch alles
aber auch wirklich alles was vorher da
drinne stand ist vergangenheit
trotzdem stehe ich dazu da hat man
gemerkt da war schon jahre zwischen
damals schon so richtig sei mein gott
das ist so als auch das mit meiner
schwester meine nachrichten gelesen hat
und ob mein ganzes leben verändert hätte
und ich danach kein tagebuch mehr
gefüttert und nix ja das war da noch kam
nichts mehr
ich habe ganz am ende der liste gemacht
häufigst genannte personen haben hat auf
jeden fall gewonnen
bei den häufig genannten personen um das
heißt dieses tagebuch ist nun vorbei h
ich weiß ich mache jetzt eine drogerie
montage mit den besten momenten viel
spaß
[Musik]
ich habe ja dann genau so viel spaß wie
ich und wer weiß wenn ich meine anderen
tag habe ich vielleicht noch finde dann
geht es auch weiter
aber das liegt in den sternen denn
momentan kann ich sie nicht finden
vielleicht kann ich euch auch schon
spoiler das mit einem gewissen marvin
gesprochen habe und der vielleicht mal
sich dazu bereit erklärt mit mir mal
über die ganzen sache zu sprechen
mal stellung zu beziehen vielleicht
sollte ich mich einfach mal bei ihm
entschuldigen für die ganze scheiße und
gerne sehen uns dann beim nächsten video
wieder und falls sie die krimiserie noch
nicht könnt hier die playlist da oben
könnt ihr mich abonnieren
da vielleicht auch im video dort sitzt
kelly und ja bis dann leute peas auf
[Musik]